can smell too bad
long
can you taste it
oh my God that [ __ ] foul
hi I'm Louis Tomlinson and you're
watching snack Wars UK versus us on lab
Bible
ah yeah whiskey
is this gin yeah oh [ __ ] you know gin's
nasty so let's start with the uh
start with the chin do people love ice
would you I think so yeah yeah go on
then I'll have a bit of ice please
let's ditch these yeah
cheers
up with the first shot of gin I've never
done me live
I can't imagine doing another that's
pretty awful actually I don't like
whiskey either so like what kind of
spirit vodka Hammer vodka kind of guy
yeah I like vodka but try new things on
it New Horizons yeah yeah yeah who knows
I'm out artists
[Laughter]
shut up
expect to be drinking at this time
oh
you don't sip shots yeah very true
you're not wrong again I'm not really a
whiskey man but
I'll go Jack Daniels on that right what
we got this time
what the [ __ ] is that
premium I guess and what this is
Scottish is it yeah I'll have a look at
back cooked lamb lungs
he met with oatmeal and spices it sounds
far why does anyone eat this no offense
to only likes it obviously what else do
they have in Scotland that didn't they
don't like deep fried Mars Bars getting
nicer than this I'm brilliant doesn't
smell too bad
long
can you taste it
oh my God
that [ __ ] fall
oh it's made my eyes water
you know
oh what the [ __ ] are you doing to me
what is it gonna taste like if you had
to put something on it well at first it
tastes like lamb and then you say can
you taste the lungs and it was like
maybe no right that's there's no chance
that's winning but what we got in here
it can only get better surely
that looks decent but messy like which
is that's [ __ ] fat anyone here like
that anyone
so I mean man you just say premium money
to be fair
I actually like hot dogs but this looks
appetite
oh [ __ ] Canal
um all right
[Laughter]
yeah it's not very American
German I believe yeah that one yeah yeah
but apparently together with these
sauces and onion it makes a New York hot
I see I see I'm gonna have to go hot dog
um it's hard to enjoy that after that to
be fair because that that is that's one
of the worst things I've tasted in a
long time now oh yeah okay so that goes
to America that point
[Music]
oh
right do you know what the Mad thing is
and I do feel bad for saying this I
actually really [ __ ] ate baked beans
unless we want to only men in England
that a well only person in England that
H baked beans yeah why don't you try
just pouring it on and then like we can
go on let me uh
and what have we got here what's this oh
I'll come to this in this section right
right
oh I can eat beans you know what for you
lot though I will get a go it must be 15
years since I've had some beans beans
and then cheese is in the other Bowl for
the audience oh yeah yeah sorry
just gonna be gross this
what don't you like about them don't
know they're just weird okay these are
cold as well
oh it's been awful man
oh that's gross man
thank you
right mac and cheese [ __ ] staple
again American right because it looks
Italian to me
though add a lot of mac and cheese or a
lot of cheesy pasta growing up as a kid
to be fair for my little lad Freddy I
make him a lot of cheesy pasta so I'd
have to go with that as uh you can eat
baked beans I think so yeah I got away
at mac and cheese we'll get them away
from you
I'll see you macky's already so I'm
already pretty happy scones
these got those weird what do they have
anymore
no idea what the way to do it is so I'll
just shred a bit of this on yeah
I'm doing it oh no what's the other way
so the other way is Jam first right and
who does that Cornwall Cornwall okay
right
oh these These are nice though
so afternoon tea well nice
yeah English staple banging got potato
yeah today but I'm not asking I'm just
saying for next time
oh apple pie okay not a massive fan of
apple pies but again
come on some kind of bush took a try or
something
oh no no I know people like them but
again I don't really like them you're
mackie's fan in general though massive
McDonald's right okay I ate far too much
McDonald's to be fair especially on
maturing in that night
big match tastes the same globally you
know what I mean yeah I'm gonna have to
go with scones really like the scones to
be fair yeah yeah embracing me posture
side
okay okay
been a little bit nicer what's this oh
is that that yeah fluff so it's kind of
like a marshmallow in a pot very
American and English Skittles yeah don't
they Taste the rainbow oh that is a
decent invention from us
you're a skittles fan I am a skittles
fan but you need to be trying the sour
ones the sour ones specifically actually
the sour ones in America
incredible
I would know all that skills
not really loud Skittles when I was
younger dead bad for achieving it yeah I
am
I do have a lot these days
just gonna taste like Skittle in it
bit weird though
um
and what this picture of a sandwich here
people have owned sandwiches well I
think yeah I think you can do whatever
you you want it's kind of like a bit
like Nutella do you know like people
okay sometimes have it out the pot and
sometimes you can just spread it yeah
that's that's a bit gross for me
actually I'm gonna go Skittles on that
okay cool
the US One
the US One they've got a few decent
snacks I'm surprised that they've won to
be fair but until next time
there's no need for that still do it
what
oh yeah all dressed
it's exciting been explaining these to
Margot Robbie
who loves snacks and doesn't doesn't
seem seems to be totally baffled by the
idea of an all an all-dressed chip but
it does exist